[Música]
estos manifestantes cantaron hasta el
anochecer para decir que sobrevivirán a
la presión del gobierno para que
trabajen más tiempo el plan del
presidente Manuel macan para ampliar la
edad de jubilación vio como más de un
millón de personas Se tomaron las calles
un sindicato cálculo más de 2 millones
de participantes en todo el país en
París se produjeron algunos
enfrentamientos con decenas de
detenciones Sin embargo el ambiente fue
mayoritariamente Pacífico con un mensaje
la reforma de las pensiones es
injustamos mucho pedirnos que hagamos un
esfuerzo más bueno ha llegado al punto
en el que no pueden empujarnos
hubo protestas masivas aquí en Marsella
así como en León montpellier innantes se
calculan unas 200 manifestaciones las
huelgas interrumpieron el transporte
público las escuelas y la administración
pública
el presidente macrón desde la Cumbre
Franco español en Barcelona defendió lo
que calificó de reforma justa y
responsable
ahora vamos a empezar a trabajar sobre
la propuesta del gobierno con el debate
en el parlamento todos los partidos
políticos de la asamblea nacional y del
senado debatirán para que podamos
aplicarla
la reforma se presentó al electorado y
ha sido validada es justa y responsable
pero los sindicatos no quieren nada de
eso y dicen que la protesta de ahora es
solo el comienzo
estamos Unidos y decididos a conseguir
esta reforma de las pensiones por eso
los sindicatos convocan una nueva
jornada de huelgas y protestas el 31 de
enero
los diputados y senadores empezarán a
estudiar la legislación propuesta a
principios de febrero el gobierno quiere
que se promulga a finales de verano
entre tanto sindicatos y trabajadores se
comprometen a pararla en Seco
[Música]